Putin's got a lot he's a former KGB
colonel this is what really pisses me
off the most when you see conservatives
on conservative websites say oh bloody
reported standing up for the West and
Christianity this is a guy who
persecuted Christians when he was a KGB
officer our next guest you can follow
him on the Twitter at Seb Gorka he's
author of New York Times bestseller
defeating jihad his new book coming out
why we fight July 23rd he's a military
intelligence analyst he was former
Deputy Assistant to United States
President Donald Trump in 2017 we've had
on the show before
dr. Gorka thank you for being here sir
hey guys great to be back this is a
whole new studio setup you got going on
there it's almost like cuz it's a CNN
quadrant view thank you like it's my new
prime studio okay well good so hopefully
no one that CNN actually has your
coordinates because there will be a
dirty bomb somewhere or it's dirty don't
worry about it just Anderson Cooper
hurling cuss words host with three eyes
open yes I survived that I'm Way beyond
Anderson Cooper's cuss words well good
I'm glad to hear so let me ask you this
today obviously it's the trend
everywhere
optics wise how do you think's has been
for president Donald Trump good bad
worse it's it seems like it wasn't a
great day yeah I'm trying to think what
else do we expect Steve I mean really
well what was that mainstream media
going to do suddenly surrender and say
oh my what a great president Donald
Trump is I'm not saying it's the best
press conference he ever gave but I can
tell you because I saw it when I was in
the Oval with him he's just fed up with
this Russia collusion absurdity yeah if
you see the way that they're mixing up
the more investigation on collusion with
the question of the election tampering
by these giu agents he's just had enough
and to think that they didn't ask one
important question about Syria nuclear
weapons Germany getting in bed with
Russia they just it's like the stroke
testimony last week they unveiled
themselves for who they are
the mainstream media isn't doing
journalism anymore scheme-y I agree
I think so I think there are two things
that are often conflated like you
touched on so one this idea that
President Trump colluded with the
Russians of which there's really no
evidence right I think we've zero we
agree on that but then number two as you
said the Russian meddling in the
election for undue influence you're in
America there seems to be some evidence
for that but two separate issues they
try to conflate them so as someone who
is generally supporter a fair critic
with Donald Trump why wouldn't president
Trump take the opportunity to distance
himself from the collusion accusations
with this fake news by by just
condemning the Russian meddling when
he's got Putin right there that's one
thing I will say is a supporter going if
he does that that helps him no I think
you know that's definitely a
hypothetical thing you could do but I
think he's just setting up fed up I mean
look at the what they've done to him and
his family when they actually say that
you know your son is committing treason
when you got the former director of the
CIA the former director of the CIA John
Brennan who before he joined the CIA at
the height of the Cold War admitted to
voting for the Communist Party and he
has the gall today to call the president
treasonous I mean in 1976 when John
Brennan did that the Soviet Union wanted
to turn us into a sheet of glass I think
that's a little bit more treasonous and
he's just being a human being Steven if
you were being attacked personally every
day in the media for being a traitor not
just the attacks you get every day but
actually being a traitor with regards to
one issue the Russian election I think
you'd be fed up too especially if they
were attacking your family I would I
would absolutely be fed up and as a
matter of fact if there if I were fed up
because they were attacking me for being
treasonous with you know a KGB former
KGB thug I think we both agree less and
not big fans of Putin I would go out of
my way to condemn the thing of which the
action for which there is evidence which
is the meddling in the United States
election let me ask you this if you were
still in your position here what how
would you handle this situation what
would you be doing here because I mean
we have we have you hear us because my
father if you read my book the first
chapters about my dad my dad at the age
of 20 was arrested tortured by communist
secret police officers and given a life
sentence in
political prison so I'm not exactly the
best person to ask about how to deal
with a KGB officer or vanity routine
you're the perfect person to ask
actually a human being I've seen his
frustration in the Oval Office
sure I remember let me share with you
this anecdote I think it was the day
Jared testified at the date Jared gave
his all press conference on the Russia
collusion garbage and I was in the oval
alone with the president and I was in
there for a completely different reason
and this Russia thing came up because of
Jared and he looked me straight in the
eye I could tell he was he was angry and
he said they will never find anything
because there is nothing I don't want to
try and give advice to a man who's in
that position and seeing his family
attacked the way they have been attacked
it's easy to say I would do it better or
I'd separate these issues at the end of
the day he is the arch communicator and
look you know CJ Pearson
JP the CJ CJ the black kid the 16 year
old black kid who's very active Twitter
I I think yeah he was a big Bernie
supporter yes yeah
well he's he made it he posted a great
tweet today he said you're accusing the
president of treason who gets up every
day to represent America's interests
look at what he's done for the last 18
months look at the economy look at
everything else most important of all
you know that under his command
we killed 200 Russian mercenaries in
Syria so let's get real which head of
state in the West all of them
NATO combined has allowed our troops to
kill Russian mercenaries that are
undermining the Middle East none of them
except Donald Trump yeah I certainly
think that Barack Obama were was a lot
weaker when it came to Russia I mean
that's there's been a quote going around
where he said what if I win the election
will be a lot more flexible it's Ben
Affleck's
yes flexible is the key word there how
words that are flexible let it not be
misconstrued President Obama so yes I I
agree well we have some questions
actually hear from from Twitter
I think this is about this is a constant
theme we toss to the audience this comes
from below cash out should we side with
our US intelligence agencies or believe
Putin then Steven Scott asks how have so
many Americans reached the point where
they trust Putin about the same as they
do the FBI DOJ CIA this was one of the
most common questions where who do
should Americans trust because that was
that was I will say the big two big bunk
over bungle from from Donald Trump today
saying I have no Rutten says no we said
so very powerfully creating an
equivalency that being said there are no
there isn't a lot of faith in a lot of
Americans institutions right now so I
don't know if it's a matter of people
who leave in prudent or just not
believing the FBI but what do you trust
if we would look to Dean's gonna like
he's a former KGB colonel who spent his
life trying to undermine America Western
civilization the idea that he's some
great national hero I mean this is what
really pisses me off the most when you
see conservatives on conservative
websites say oh bloody reported standing
up for the West and Christianity this is
a guy who persecuted Christians when he
was a KGB officer right let's just get
serious so you don't trust him number
one but to say - dichotomy between
trusting him and the US intelligence
services
let's get hyper factual this 17
intelligence agencies or 15 - it's
garbage it's not true if you read dnase
report the Director of National
Intelligence did not say we have a
consensus in fact they were dissenting
opinions from five or six of the US
intelligence agencies what we do know is
that there are Russian fingerprints on
actions to do with the last election
especially the code that was used and
the kind of encryption that was used to
target various internet capacities and
now we have the molar indictments and
Stephen let's be serious about the
murder indictments as then I think was
Nigel Faraj summarized it well well well
we indicted 12 spies for spying I'm
shocked there's gambling in this casino
I mean really I mean it's like
Casablanca and commander Renault these
things have been going on for decades
yeah I did something happened especially
in 2016
they've been
doing this since about 1918 and now the
Democrats are worried about it come on
let's be real this is about this is
about politics not about getting to the
truth
well actually brief you to another
question this comes from collected said
what could Russia and the USA do
together that would greatly benefit the
people of both countries and I ask you
that because it's kind of tough to do
something to work together with someone
who's an ex-kgb thug like you said it is
there anything that could be done to
sort of thaw this icy relationship you
think that's what the president's trying
to do if it were in your hands would you
make the effort knowing Putin's past I'd
use the levers that I know he responds
to okay
and I think it's not about making nice
you don't make nice with a KGB thug he's
never gonna be our friend he's never
going to be our friend
right so you express power you reassert
leadership the fact that he didn't
respond to our killing his Russian
mercenaries is very telling that tells
you that he's a little bit worried at
the very very least I just like him to
stand down from his meddling whether
it's in the Ukraine whether it's in
Syria the fact is we've had four hundred
thousand people killed in Syria and
Russia isn't exactly always on the side
of the good guy so I think it's trying
to put him a little bit back into his
box not with some kind of rose-tinted
expectation that we're gonna hold hands
and collaborate on issues together I
don't think that's ever gonna happen
okay a final question um I think vitomir
Putin talked about a four hundred
million dollars at the press conference
to Hillary Clinton's campaign can you
can you clarify that at all for a lot of
people are going on us and we kind of
skimmed over this do we know what that
is a lot of people are curious I know I
am look I don't work for him I'm not a
press folks but for Vladimir Putin I
think you may be doing he may be trying
to emulate the president for or try and
compete with him for the role of master
troll you know the media will be
obsessing about this for the next six
months if not longer so I I have no idea
what we do know is you know they spent
what a hundred thousand dollars on
Facebook which got Michael Moore to
participate in an anti-trump rally in
New York these are facts these are facts
what this 400,000 is I don't know that's
aweso crowd at 400 million nother
hundred thousand foot I think Putin
score that is a big win Michael Moore
will show up to protest plus I will get
him walking it's a win-win for six
people he counts for a few yeah that was
one of the facts to me that was that I
wanted today to take an opportunity to
at least kind of clarify and illuminate
but that is just about as funny as it
gets I mean the fact that the only
person really fooled here undeniably
there's consent is Michael Moore more
perfectly than that
all right listen we have to get we don't
have to talk about your new book why we
fight dr. Gorka tell us about that and
where people can find it right so it's
it's on Amazon right now for pre-order
I'll be coming out soon it's it's
basically my analysis of what threatens
America who the big threats are out
there like Russia like China like Isis
how to deal with them and to actually
make people want to read it it's not
just dry analysis
it's interspersed with stories of great
American heroes that that a lot of us
have forgotten going way back to our
first jihadi war the Barbary war a great
great story a guy called Stephen Decatur
naval officer that led the 1st Marine
Corps special operation against
jihadists 200 years ago right up through
Vietnam Korea and then lastly you know
my assertion is you don't just have to
be wearing a uniform to be a hero so
there's a vignette there's a story on
Whittaker Chambers because I think a lot
of people who watch your show I mean
we're crushing it the ride is crushing
it when it comes to the Internet we are
the new counterculture but I'm not sure
a lot of Millennials know Whittaker
Chambers and the truth behind Alger Hiss
so
you know little stories and vignettes of
great American heroes that's fantastic I
think a lot of people should read it if
I actually think Joe Rogan recently was
talking about a lot of conspiracy
theorists who you see on the right and
saying I'll go into all these conspiracy
theories but how many of them can really
talk about Fidel Castro while we're
taking the government of them can really
give you history on Che Guevara is like
so that's kind of cool to be
anti-authoritarian but you do have to
know your facts you do have to also
start going
down the path of learning history and
stories and anecdotes are a great way to
do that that's the foreground and in the
background is the whole historical
context it is why we fight out July 23rd
at Seb Gork hey thank you so much
brother for being on we appreciate it if
you like this video subscribe or click
the notification bell right next to the
subscription but because absque reiben
doesn't mean anything anymore now
according to the YouTube gods and if you
like the late night show you can watch
it every single day a full hour at LOD
with credit com / mug clubs subscribe
there that way we aren't beholden to the
evil YouTube overlords and we don't have
to start playing video games with mouth
sound effects or children react